when you live by other people's rules  you're not gonna give yourself a chance  to take a step back right now and think  about who we all admire in the world  right they're all people that punted the  system there are people that practice  singing since they were 5 there were  people that shot ten thousand  basketballs every morning it's always  that it's always that 99% of people  right now that are listening to this are  playing in the middle they're playing in  a game that was structured for them  they're risk adverse they fear and most  importantly they fear what other people  think Elvis I think the best thing that  ever happened to me  much like you with your gold mic I  didn't care what other people said and  and it's not because I didn't respect it  I actually I get feedback all the time  that might be negative listen I respect  it I listen to it but at the end of the  day I'm just not built to have it  dictate my one at-bat at life